welcome back everyone it's round two uh
recap of battle of the sexes from
gibraltar
uh in this game i played jovanka houska
she's a well-known commentator player
uh author
and she actually has a book on the caro
khan
and i decided to play e4 this game and
test her caro khan
um and this is basically her her main
opening for black it was only thing i
was really preparing for and i decided
to play a two nights attack
which
maybe the the super fans of this channel
would know
i made a video a few months ago
on how to crush the kero khan in which i
show a lot of different traps
emerging from this line
now unbeknownst to me i only found out
this after the game
is that she actually watched that video
and had some idea of landmines for white
and of course um was prepared for this
she took
i took and played knight to f6
and this is one of the main lines and i
played the the most trendy move these
days is queen to e2
and at first this move looks a little
bit
anti-positional because i do block the
bishop but the point is to align on
e-file
and threaten to take and force black to
take back with the g-pawn
there's also a nice trap here if knight
b to d7
white is mating in one with knight d6
this would be a nice mother mate but of
course she did not fall into that
uh she took
i took
and now the main move here is queen to
d5
uh just going for the queen trade and uh
i had some preparation here but she
played a uh a sideline
queen to a5
which i was mildly prepared for like i
was aware of this move i'll admit i
didn't look at this move before the game
but i looked at this move like a few
weeks ago when i was just doing general
preparation
and the move i had in store to me queen
a5 is pawn to b4
so hitting the queen
getting some initiative
she played very quickly queen to f5
going for a queen trade
and here i played basically the last
move
of my preparation queen to e3 and this
is a gambit
i am giving away a pawn
now it's very risky for black to take it
because after queen c2 i would have
bishop d3
uh queen a4
and i'd probably play bishop to b2 here
stacking yet another pawn
and if we entered this position it would
have been just a complete uh chaotic
mess
given that white is down two pawns
but i'm pretty much complete with
development and play rook b1 in this
position
and this would have been a really fun
position to play
i'm a little bit disappointed we didn't
get to play this out it does have some
resemblance to the danish gambit or
white sax two pawns for very open
position two bishops more development
but she played
a much safer move here queen to e6
which is one of the strategies for black
in a position like this
is to get queens off the board early
and steer the game into more strategic
and positional battle
so this was what i was uh i guess i was
expecting more
and i went ahead and played bishop to b2
and after takes takes
we reach a position uh queens are off
the board early but there's definitely
some imbalances with pawn structure i
have a slight lead in development
and he or she played a very typical move
for the position
even though maybe it would make ben
feingold cringe
is pawn f6
now there are cases where you should
sometimes play f6 and this is one of
them
um it's actually a very useful move for
black to blunt the power of my dark
sword bishop and prepare pawn e5 and
then eventually activate black star
squared bishop
so
i had a small think here deciding how to
complete development
and decided to play the most natural
bishop c4
she played pawn e5 attacking pawn on b4
i played a3 and now she played pawn a5
so probably the most confrontational
move forcing me to decide how to deal
with the pawn tension of course black is
threatening to take
and at first i wanted to play b5 but i
think this would just lose time for
white after takes takes bishop d7
i'd be having to move this bishop a
bunch of times
so
instead i decided to take
and after rook takes a5 we reach a
position where i have all my minor
pieces developed
black has no minor pieces developed just
so rook developed and i figured now is a
good time to try and open up the
position
and i went ahead and played pawn d4
which i thought is the most kind of
thematic move um challenging the
the pawn chain um trying to make this
bishop have some life now
this move gives black essentially two
options i have three attackers on e5 so
black has to decide whether to take or
play e4
and in the game she played e4 which i
think is a safer move if lack takes here
i would take back with epon
and then the e5 would be open i'd be
ready to castle gather rook to e1 and
start targeting the king and box king
would maybe
be a little bit
difficult to find a safe place for it
given that it's hard to castle for black
so after e4 the position
closed down a little bit but i was happy
to see this move because after knight t2
the epon's a little bit
overextended and black doesn't
necessarily want to play f5 even though
it depends upon
could allow for some potential
g4 at some point
and black is still very much behind
development
not to mention maybe someday i could go
for like bishop e3 c4 and d5 unleash my
dark square bishop
so she decided to play bishop to f5
defending the pawn but this gives me a
chance to castle
and attack the bishop get the rook to
the half open file
she plays bishop g6
and here i i really wanted to try and
target the pawn right away
with a move like rook f4
but this would allow uh bishop d6 and
then my rook would be hit and then
eventually f5 would probably come
so i figured that i just want to improve
and one way to improve in this position
is to play a4
to uh essentially prevent any prospect
of black plane b5 but also
get the pawn off a square where it was
attacked twice
so essentially this this move
um it fights for a little bit of space
on the queen side
and later on my plan is to play
some uh some move like bishop c3 and
knight b3 and eventually get the pawn to
a5 and get some positional bind on the
queen side now the drawback of a4
it did allow bishop to b4
hitting my knight
and
i thought for a bit because i could play
knight b3 but i wanted to keep some
pressure
against e4 pawn so i played pawn c3
now at first this move looks just
terrible given that uh my bishop is now
stuck behind the pawn chain
but i do get tempo against black's
bishop
and i thought long term eventually i
will play c4 someday
and uh and expand on the queen side and
make this bishop happy again
so
she played bishop to e7
now i will note if bishop d6 my plan was
to play bishop to b3 to prepare knight
c4
and the bishop would be a bit
exploitable on d6 on top of that i'd
have ideas of bishop c2
[Music]
to pressure the pawn so bishop b7 i
think was very reasonable
and here i play bishop to e6 so uh this
move looks a little bit
over ambitious
because i just go in deep into black's
territory the bishop's not supported by
anything
but
this was intended to be a prophylactic
move
i was trying to tie down black as much
as possible
with the bishop on e6 it's more
difficult for bach to play f5
if we look at f5 here i would have
knight c4
the rook would have to move away and
then i win the pawn so um f5 is not
playable
and
black can't easily castle of course
and i'm ready to either play knight c4
or knight b3 or pawn c4 so i thought
bishop e6 was a nice way of making
progress in the position
and
one more thing to note if bishop to f7 i
would have bishop f5 and this pawn would
be a goner
so
not easy to find uh find a color plan
for black here
but she did develop her final minor
piece with knight d7
and i play knight b3 hitting the rook
rook a7
and now pawn to c4
so uh expanding on the queen side this
is a move i i was hoping to play uh back
when i played pawn c3
and when i played pawn c4 i was
calculating
a funny line it was a very deep line
which we didn't go into but i do want to
show it because
it featured some cool kind of board
geometry
uh because i thought one candidate move
for black here would be knight to f8 to
try and remove the bishop
and
force some trades
and against this move i was going to
play bishop to f5
offering the train of bishops after
takes takes
the threat is rook f4 to win the pawn
so it looks very natural for black to
play pawn g6 here to get in the eventual
pawn chain
connect four pawn chain
and against this move it spotted the
really nice resource rook a5
essentially forcing
a trait of rooks
and after takes takes
in the very end i have a fork against
the pawns and white would be winning a
pawn here
now
after i played c4 i realized there's a
move rook a6
but then it's still interesting because
after takes takes knight d2 f5 there's
d5 hitting the the rook and the pawn
so i was doing some very deep
calculations here
uh this is one of the nice things about
having a lot of time to think in a
classical game and really delve into the
position and uh
and be imaginative with various
calculations
but um
she took a long think after i played c4
and rather than playing knight to f8 she
played the move which i didn't even
consider at all is rook to f8
which has some logic to it it does
in some cases support f5
other case it allows for bishop f7 and
then rook takes off seven
so here i took another think and decided
to just improve the position further
play pawn a5 i figured this would be a
move i would play eventually
pawn is well supported and it fixes a
pawn on b7
so she played bishop f7 we trade
takes takes
and
here there's an interesting battle on
the king side
given that the pawn is still a bit
overextended and there's a few different
ways for me to attack it
and the move i initially wanted to play
was rook f4
but after pawn f5
if i go for a g4 there's bishop g5
and then e3 turns out to be
quite vulnerable here
so instead of playing rogue four
immediately i decided to play g4 first
uh preventing this whole idea of f5 and
bishop g5 and i thought that was a bit
clever because now i prepare rook f4
and if i get one more move in i am
winning the pawn on e4
so black has to be precise here she
played what um i think the best move is
is pawn h5 uh maybe an alternative is g6
and then f5
but h5 was quite interesting because
i didn't necessarily want to take
and allow f5
and then i have less pressure against
the pawn
so
i decided to maintain the pawn on g4
with h3
we trade takes takes
and now she plays g6 so preparing f5 and
here i um
i had a decision to make there is a line
that
i wanted to go into but it would have i
think just simplified everything
uh the move i wanted to play was rook f4
hitting the pawn
but after pawn f5
takes takes
rook f1
i'm winning this pawn but again black
has this resource bishop g5 and after it
takes takes king g2
takes takes
this position a lot of pawns have come
off the board
maybe white has some slight chances but
after move like b6 i think there's going
to be more trades and this would be very
likely
uh to be a draw
and i thought i had a slight advantage
just given i have more space
on
the queen side have have some positional
play on both the king side
and the queen side so instead of playing
rook f4 i played rook f2
which prevents idea of bishop g5 tip the
rook
and the plan is still the same as to
double up and then eventually go after
this pawn
with a move maybe to start with bishop
c3 and then knight d2
so here she played pawn to b6 and it was
a fascinating position because there's a
strategic battle on both the king side
and the queen side
and we kind of both had to juggle the
different ideas on on both sides of the
board
and with b6 she's just trying to
neutralize
my my queen side play trade off my my
strong a5 pawn
and i didn't really want to take because
after rook takes a1 one of my pieces
would have to go into the corner and
then the knight would come alive on b6
to target c4
so instead i played bishop c3
reinforcing the pawn
she played bishop d8
and here i play knight d2 so going after
e4 pawn essentially forcing black to
play f5
and now i play rook a2 f1 so just
abandoning a5 pawn and trying to win f5
palm
because in the event that black takes on
a5 i would take
take take and then e4 would be
very weak and i think white would have
good chances
to to play for a win in this position
so instead what happened
is she played a very nifty move
bishop to h4
which
forces my rook off that file if i play
rook f4
keeping the pressure
then bishop g3 just traps my rook
during the game i i was worried about
bishop to g5 but bishop g3 is even
stronger
and my rook would be gone
so
i had anticipated bishop h4 and saw the
idea to play rook h2
bishop moves back to g5 so now e3 is
hanging it's kind of awkward to defend
but i was banking on the idea
rook to h8
and what this move does is forces block
to make
some concession to get out of check
uh black has three legal moves here rook
f8 knight f8
and he or she fought for at least five
minutes uh deciding what move to play
eventually decided on king e7
i will note if nayla f8 that leaves upon
a defendant and
i'd be able to take maybe it's still
playable for black because there is
bishop e3 uh with check
but uh
i i would have been fine there and if
rook f8
i would take take and then f5 would hang
and i thought in these lines i would
have good chances to still play for a
win
so king e7 was definitely the most
challenging move
and i spent a long time here trying to
just figure out what's going on because
position can get very very messy very
quickly
i essentially had two candidate moves
between bishop b4
and pawn takes b6 and i really wanted to
play bishop to b4 check
which
almost wins by force point being if
kingi six and then there's rook to
e a check
and then the king is almost animating
that if king f6
there is my beloved pork a pin plus the
fork and white would be winning the
bishop after king g7 knight g5
and then there's a funny line if bishop
e7
bishop is pinned from behind the king is
very vulnerable
and my calculation was d5 check
after takes takes
in
one way or another the king will be
driven away from defending the bishop if
takes then i win the bishop
and if king f6
again there's knight takes e4 but i was
calculating g5 and again the bishop will
eventually be lost
so
i was optimistic about
this move but black has a resource pawn
c5
and then there's a really complicated
line which i think i'll have to analyze
further with engine because
it could have gotten really messy after
it takes
and
as in between move attacking the rook
black would take here
king h1
and now the rook can move to b7
and after it takes
it looks good for white given that i
have three pawns ready to march down the
board
bishop align with the king but after
bishop takes e5
it appears as if black is is completely
fine and i thought these pawns could
maybe be a
a hassle to deal with
now the engine
engine just gives a quality in this
position so i guess stockfish knows best
but i decided not to go for that and
instead played pawn takes b6
which in some sense is upon sacrifice
because i lose e3
black delivers check
played king h1 and now knight takes v6
and i'm down a pawn here and for some
reason during the game i didn't realize
i was down a pawn
uh given that
the e3 would just fell off the board and
i'm not winning the pawn back uh so
cleanly
so the move i played here was was a bit
fancy is knight takes e4
and i was banking on uh tactics working
for me because black can't take back if
pawn takes e4 i take takes and then
skewer and when the
rook on a7 and end
unfortunately after knight takes e4 i'm
still under a lot of pressure
and she could have played knight takes
c4 immediately and still be off a pawn
and then it's up to me to equalize
but she played the move rook to a4
so keeping a lot of pressure
uh threatening the pawn again
and now my knight is actually hanging
because i don't have the same tactic of
rook f7 and rook h7
so i was getting really low on time at
this point
ron moved 35 i moved 40 we get an extra
half hour but i had just a couple
minutes to make my next five moves
and i uh
as you'll see i kind of freaked out and
did not handle the position
as best as possible
um i started with pontix f5 this is
completely fine g takes f5
and then i played rook to e1
hitting the bishop unfortunately she's
able to leave the bishop on e3 and take
on c4
and
yeah just go up a pawn and now my knight
is still attacked
i play knight to c5
and
she played rook to a2
so this is move 38 i have two more moves
to
go until i get more time
and it was a very difficult position to
try and navigate
with almost no time on the clock
i played the move rook to b1 which i
thought was useful to go for counter
play against box king engine is giving
one move to maintain equality rook h6
which i didn't even consider
uh idea is a bishop is pinned to the
king so there's no bishop h6 and there's
a cool threat of rook takes e3 and rook
e6
so maybe if i had more time i would have
found this move
but after rook to b1
she played rook c2
and this is where i just kind of freaked
out i let my time
tick all the way down to two seconds
and then i had flashbacks of
the first round game where i flagged
right i thought i made my move quick
enough i didn't so i saw my time was at
two seconds and i very quickly blitzed
out bishop a1
which is a really sad move to play
putting my bishop in the corner my
bishop's locked by the d-pawn but it was
an attempt to just stay alive
and at this point i knew i was just
trying to hold on for dear life
she played the move knight d6
and we finally reached blue 40.
i have
30 more minutes
to
try and
deal with with this position i was not
happy with how the last several moves
unfolded
i'm now down upon
my king is is just cornered
my bishop is terrible this pawn is weak
black has a past f on
i was feeling very very pessimistic
and then i had a cool idea
i had an idea
if i just sacrifice
my rook my bishop my pawn my knight my
other rook
it would be stalemate
so there's a funny line
pawn d5
oh no my pawn
oh no my rook
oh no my knight
oh no my bishop
check
and oh no my other rook and it would be
stalemate
unfortunately none of this is forcing
black would have like multiple
opportunities to make me and in that
line i just showed but uh
the funny line did cross my mind
unfortunately uh yeah it's it's not too
realistic
and the move i played here to try and
just hold on
is rooked h2
and for those that analyzed the game
with engine
stockfish gave this as a terrible
terrible blunder
it turned out there is only one move
to
be slightly worse for white is knight d3
i didn't play this move because i was
scared of black going in for mating
ideas with knight e4 apparently white
has enough counter play with rook b7
but uh
yeah it was a terrifying position and i
played rook h2 with idea just to try and
trade brooks
and hold the position down the pawn
uh the problem is after rook takes h2
king takes h2
pawn f4
black is just rolling down the board
pawn f3 is now
a major idea my pieces are still
not the best placed my king is out of
play
and
this is the position we reached i
realized i'm probably gonna lose this
game but i thought might as well try and
fight as much as i can
decided to play knight to d3
she plays king e6
uh which is aiming to bring the king
well into the position very typical in
endgame you want to use the king as an
act of
i played king to g2 trying to get a
blockade on f3
and after king to f5
i played king f3 and now rook to g7
threatening to play rook g3
and here i
really wanted to play rook b6
which attempts to
win the pawn
and if i can win this pawn and then sack
my knight for the other pawn i thought
maybe there are some chances to survive
in a a pawnless end game where i have
rook and bishop versus rook knight and
bishop the problem with rook b6 is bach
has a cool forcing line
rook g3
forcing king e2
rook g2
and my intention would have been to go
back to f3 if i move to the first ring
there's rook g1 to pick up the bishop
but after king f3 there's rook to d2
and
all of a sudden
i don't have a great way to
hold on given that if i move my knight
let's say 95 then rook f2 is mate
and there's a few interesting lines here
uh which i was calculating if i take on
c6
black can take on d3 and then if i take
the knight
there's bishop takes d4
with discover check
and when i first saw this i was actually
hopeful that
even though it looks like i'm losing a
bishop there's a pin
the problem is i only have two legal
moves
and after either move let's say kingi 2
the rook will deliver a check and then
black will win the bishop and win the
game same thing with king ji2 rook g3
check
so
i i was sad when i saw this because it's
really really close
uh to white's holding on another line i
wanted to play was knight takes f4 here
but then after bishop takes f4
rook takes c6
it looks like i'm getting what i want an
end game where maybe i can survive with
rook bishop against
rook knight and bishop the problem is
after knight e4
i'm just in a mating that there's
actually no good way to stop
knight g5
and there's there's no good checks
against the black king rook c5 there's
knight takes e5
so
going all the way back to
[Music]
this position
i wanted to play rook b6 but given the
lines i just showed it didn't seem like
any of that worked for me
so i decided to play rook to b8
and attempt
to get counter play along the back rank
she continued here with rook 2 g3
forcing kini 2
and this is where she finally showed
some mercy
black is still better here after a move
like rook g2
king f3 and then rook g1
and i i'd still be
just hanging on by a thread
but instead she played the move knight
to c4
which
just allowed me exactly what i want is
uh checks along the back rank
and this move is hard to explain i'm not
entirely sure what she overlooked
but i will say it was a very
difficult battle up until this point
and
sometimes in the later stages of the
game it can be
easier to make oversights
and after rook f8
it's very difficult for black to escape
the checks in the game she played king
g5 i keep checking king h4 rookie chase
king g4 rook g8
and it's possible she overlooked that
after king h3
rook h8
black cannot play
king g2
because after knight e1
uh the king is getting
almost mated here king ji won only legal
move
and then after knight f3 if king g2 i
have rook h2 mate so black would need to
stack exchange and there's no way i'm
losing this if anything white's playing
for a win here
so i was very fortunate that the king
can't
can't go in deep
and instead of going in all the way um
she played king g4
and
i should also mention she was getting
very low on the clock
fell below a minute looking for some way
to keep the game going but i continue
checking
and eventually we repeated three times
and the game ended in a draw
so
as a very intense battle
i was very fortunate not to lose this
game given that
in the endgame i was
dead lost at least according to the
engine
at a few different points
um but it was a very interesting game i
i felt good with opening overall opening
preparation
at some point maybe i i could have
maximized my chances to play for a win
but uh yeah this pretty much wraps up
round two
uh it's been some fun game so far
i will say i was super exhausted after
the game
had no energy to do the recap last night
so uh
thankfully i'm feeling more energized
this morning
and uh i should probably get going
because the next round starts in about
five hours from the time of this
recording
so today i'll be playing uh nino
batsyashvili
who is a very solid player very strong
player i have the black pieces so stay
tuned
as always i'll leave links below in the
video description to
all the tournament information live
broadcast elite chess broadcast results
and pairings so i encourage people to
follow live
and if you have any questions leave them
below and i'll look forward to seeing
you in the next video